you like a [ __ ] superstar dude you
got all these cameras on you a shed did
you have the grapes here yet the
gigantic one they taste like the Korean
grape tree
yeah it is exactly like that oh hello
Oh forgive me Oh
okay so we got the e cheat on a diamond
that everybody has been suggesting that
I get I don't know what I'm doing right
now with this I have my preferred
firmness on the noodles and you guys
know me and ramen and when it comes to
food I'm down with it baby ooh delicious
I don't want to do this egg just crack
it in there I think it's a soft-boiled
egg well I'm about to have some of this
so i'ma let y'all know what it tastes
like a little bit later each other
laughing all the way [ __ ]
motherfu so you call you bar tafoni
right now no cuz I didn't realize that
all oh my [ __ ] god we got to do
another replay this [ __ ] I got to have
it
there's Miley's like 10 or 12 time
you're left with the hurt neck is sore
ergonomic would you guys want to sample
my neck please follow where the bruise
lines are right there she's about to
toss about this dessert right here so it
is hard wait were you buzzing oh yeah
dad cover explain what a cheese tart is
group okay it's a cheese tart is like
this away it's like it's like a crust
like a pie crust and in the center is
Chi started okay okay so Pablos and if
this cheese tart that's like this big
and it's like a meringue e frothy
she cake thing it's just like Japanese
expertise in a cheesecake she read the
manual
she website so what is it your husband
described the Cheesecake tart at a
cheesecake he says it's a crust and then
it did cheese she started I can't do
[ __ ] around you I can't be myself always
turning that was yourself right there
you iced a recording you even coded it I
use it I cut it I'm gonna cut it out
because my battery's bad attitude
no good how do you feel focus other
things so good not a Johanna tude it's a
number one
is this a karaoke bar are we a karaoke
bar I wish you had a karaoke bar so
exactly what are we doing here
we're shooting sound stuff quit it go to
another one go downstairs
we're about to get smashed we're about
to get hit we're gonna get drunk
I don't drink though so he knew I do not
know any injury I don't drink it all
just the other day probably can look
down now cuz I'm a little drunk I'm
drunk
startled means I choked
didn't work you touch my bottle
you touch my bottle or oh yeah so we're
looking for a place to drink right now
after our first place was quite the bust
we had a we had a basically a $10 cover
charge per each person to basically to
do [ __ ] nothing and then they're even
nice about it but I don't know how but
they ripped us off but I still feel good
about myself the magic of Japan just you
Katie told me that that was two menus
one of them was Japanese
the other one was English English and in
the Japanese menu the beer everything
everything was cheaper on okay so the
beer was like 630 yeah and then exactly
in the English menu all the Japanese
maybe this is about 300 that's crazy
something that me yeah I don't feel so
good anymore surprises just didn't even
speak English so what happened there is
that four seats available out of six
total so it's a bus okay basically on
spot number two Michael over here pulled
the Chinese card where he asked for no
cover charge because we had seven people
that's why you always need a Chinese
[ __ ] with you because he will
always find a way to get a deal hey hey
guys no cover charge put two hours only
Michael you [ __ ] gangster dude we
call that in critic John kiseki nice
Chinese [ __ ] basically you need
butthole candy
but thank God oh well being me and
Michael I'm gonna give an injured beard
because he called the Doozer beer injera
slogan scenario Mike I know you like to
drink this much did you know you like
get wet Oh
what's wet butt naked engineer but see
you in general I just did in this suit I
just never seen like you drank I never
drink lies I never trained you drink
beer like a mofo ankle is a heavyweight
I'm saying you know your poem they're
all surprised did this fool drinks he
also [ __ ] hookers like there's like a
lot of things we don't know about Mike
I'd love to see ready for Jack Daniels
victory for harder I'm not ready for
Jack pannier than your son so we just go
to something called ninja beer I have no
idea about the flavor of this but
apparently some lager
we're about to find out what this tastes
like hallelujah guys these brain tastes
like hearin what are you doing what are
you doing to it
Oh
ah so I just spit back my ninja beer
because apparently we're waiting for
something else you'd be rude that's dude
listen to me
remember that one time I smashed a beer
ball on your face FASTA beer then this
one this later after beer
I don't like a chaser I like a tasting
the flavor of a beer I do that later no
put down you drink with me later drink
beer first
okay why it's a boy know how to party
even though he's a half accordion she'd
say oh yeah you talking about
I'm a peel ago I don't want to get
sentimental it's just [ __ ] tiring do
YouTube is so tiring sometimes man told
me it's not a sentimental thing is
[ __ ] [ __ ] sometimes leave me a break
man I want capture my face I want to
capture the emotion in the moment we are
in Japan was the last [ __ ] time any
of us ever got to do this [ __ ] it's been
a long time for me dude
and we're [ __ ] doing videos [ __ ] you
said right yeah long [ __ ] time dude
no that's all that's it that's it
sometimes
I'll do it
redo Redux three toes yeah here you
finish the beer beauty be by Betty Boop
bop bop but with Japan [ __ ] the [ __ ]
[ __ ] konichiwa [ __ ] Oh No
yeah something's happening yeah
something's coming over him Oh dad
what's wrong with your shoulders I don't
know it's good what's wrong what's wrong
with the other shoulder that one's good
at a key to what those are your neck oh
oh it's gonna sorry what's wrong with
your whole body
well I got probably one more swig left
in this to Friendship my friends to
friends today was a success it wasn't
successive it took a while though took
like two hours for the success are we
children
Oh